hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast global cannabis
regulation and testing standards
presented by donald land PhD chief
scientific consultant for steep hill
labs I am Judy O'Rourke of lab routes
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinths laberd's is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before I begin I'd like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing a presentation
please click on the help desk button
located in the promotional board at the
bottom center of your screen or use the
ask a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
land I will now turn the presentation
over to him hi thanks very much Judy I
appreciate the opportunity given to us
by labyrinth to help educate folks on
both the need and the details of
regulatory requirements as they stand
and kind of where we think they should
be going in the future i'm donald land
i'm the chief scientific consultant for
steep hill i'm also a professor of
chemistry at the university of
california davis i need to make sure
that you understand that I am NOT
representing the University of
California they want me to make sure
that I state that yeah and
know that in a way that is not to be
misunderstood for various reasons I do
want to rec refer to a few of the folks
that have helped in collecting and
interpreting the data that I'm going to
show Reverend dr. Kim Rhonda Caesar is a
is an herbalist and healer that I've
worked with for many years who's
contributed greatly Reggie got Dino PhD
is our chief scientist and is also our
chief geneticist runs the genetics
program as well as the intellectual
property program and he oversees a lot
of the genetics work that I'll be
showing Keith Allen is our
bioinformatics lead and he runs a team
of bioinformatics ists
that work on some of the data and
there's definitely several other folks
and I'll refer to a few probably in the
talk as I get going
so certainly steep hill is a science
team as well as a business entity and as
scientists one of our big goals is to
educate folks and so having lab rubes
give us this opportunity to help educate
some folks is is really important to us
and we participate as much as we can in
those kinds of activities one of the
things I'd like to educate people about
is this concept of what's in cannabis so
we hear that all the time what is what
is in cannabis what's the difference
between indica sativa a hundred years
ago if you had gone into a pharmacy or
an apothecary you would have been
presented with two different jars of
cannabis one labeled cannabis indica and
one labeled cannabis sativa and
depending on what malady was was going
to be treated one might get indica or
sativa but generally they were they were
prescribed or doled out by the
pharmacist for different reasons so
indicas are easy to identify
I over at least in those days were by
their short bushy plant structure they
have darker leaves and the leaves have
very broad broad of the fans in them
because also we're known to have a more
relaxed kind of body high or down high
as they would say
whereas sativas again easy to tell by
looking at the the structure of the
plant they're very tall very lanky they
have lighter colors they there their
buds are less dense very narrow leaves
and those were generally expected to and
and achieve a more active energetic type
of what they called a heady high and so
there were very different effects
between those two that was 100 years ago
nowadays when I look at the out outward
appearance of a plant and I see that it
looks like a sativa or it looks like an
indica when I do the chemical analysis
of what's inside it's a 50/50 right so
there's been so much hybridization and
crossbreeding in these plants nowadays
that the outward appearance and the
inward chemical content are not welcomed
correlated and therefore you don't know
by looking at it what's in it so that's
one important thing and at steep hill
we've we've generally gone away from
calling things indicas or sativas and
instead we talk specifically about the
chemical content when we're discussing
the the nature of different strains or
varietals in general cannabis is like
any other plant I its water and
cellulose and little protein and lipids
what's mostly special about cannabis is
the presence of significant amounts of
cannabinoids and we see over 30% in in
you know rare instances about not
uncommon ly in the mid to high twenty
percent of the total dry weight being
cannabinoids it also has lots of
terpenoids
that's not particularly unique to
cannabis terpenoids are produced by lots
and all plants pretty much and some
plants are very rich in terpenoids
cannabis is rich in terpenoids as well
as being rich in cannabinoids and so
that makes it very unique and very
useful from the medicinal standpoint
because both cannabinoids and terpenoids
tend to have a wide range of medicinal
effects this list here of the different
components of cannabis well frankly we
study almost all of them in one way or
another in steep hills our new program
looking at a little more detail the
cannabinoids are special to connect to
cannabis from the standpoint of almost
no other plant produces significant
amounts of cannabinoids there are a few
plants that produce small amounts of
cannabinoids cannabis is by far the
champion in producing large amounts of
cannabinoids the most frequently
encountered and the most frequently
sought cannabinoid is THC
tetrahydrocannabinol or sometimes called
Delta nine tetrahydrocannabinol which is
a little more specific about the
structure um and that is by far the most
commonly produced so and that's not a
that's not a surprise and then it's not
an accident over probably many millennia
and certainly for the last dozens of
years there's been a lot of
hybridization and breeding aimed at
increasing the amount of THC produced by
the plants and THC is easy to to detect
by a human because it causes psycho
activity one of the very few compounds
in cannabis that causes any psycho
activity most of the other cannabinoids
do not produce psycho activities THC
that produces psycho activity but it
turns out THC is not produced by the
plant and that's gonna be surprising to
some folks plants actually produce
something called THC acid and the acid
form is what's present in all fresh
plant samples and even the majority of
aged plant samples if they're only aged
a few weeks or a few months still it's
almost all THC
acid form and almost none of the neutral
form the acid form of THC THC a is not
psychoactive and so we have to heat it
when you heat th da then you can get the
psychoactive THC form so that's why it's
either smoked or vaporized or cooked all
of those methods will convert the THC a
into the psychoactive THC without that
the then cannabis itself is not
psychoactive one of the important
aspects of THC a is that it's
anti-inflammatory and so if you look
below each of the there's four different
cannabinoids shown on this slide THC th
T V and the last THC a and th yeah on
the right those are closely related and
you can see that under each of them
there's kind of a list of a couple of
different medicinal effects and
generally speaking the lists the length
of the list has more to do with how much
that compound has been studied and
probably those lists will all get longer
the THC a being not psychoactive has not
been the one sought after even though
depending on how its consumed that might
be the major one that you get one of the
important aspects there is that it's
anti-inflammatory we'll come back to
that so it's not psychoactive but it is
anti-inflammatory THC tends to give you
that psycho activity and distracts you
from pain and so behaves in a different
way underneath and each of those
cannabinoids and to the right side you
see a list of what are terpenoids those
terpenoids are have similar medicinal
effects as what's listed there and so
they're thought to act synergistically
with the cannabinoids when they're
present at the same time and I mean in
the cannabis literature this has been
referred to by ethan russo and and folks
since then as the ensembl effect or the
entourage effect to give you a little
bit broader perspective here's a bigger
picture of that same kind of information
and so you can see up at the top what
the plants actually produce are these
acid can
CBG a can have a derelict acid and that
CBG a gets then enzymatically converted
into either THC a CBD a or CCA
in today's marketplace across the world
generally speaking THCA and CBD a are
really the only options that you have
CBC a it's very very rare and that
exists only really in research labs to
any degree but those acid forms it turns
out all seem to be very good
anti-inflammatories so they don't cause
any psycho activity but they do act as
good anti-inflammatories and in fact
probably better anti-inflammatories than
hydrocortisone so there's some workout
feeling that the the acid cannabinoids
are better anti-inflammatories then even
steroidal anti-inflammatories and the
good news is because they're
non-steroidal they don't have the same
kind of symptoms the same kind of side
effects I should say as stay
hydrocortisone so they don't work in the
adrenal cortex they don't mess up your
other hormones and steroids they work
way downstream in some some enzymes that
are active in the in the inflammation
process so in particular they've been
shown to bind and and reduce the
activity of Cyclops you the
cyclooxygenase one and two and in those
cases they reduce inflammation and
therefore reduce the pain of
inflammation but they don't have any
psycho activity so you can use these as
anti-inflammatories without that psycho
activity and without really any other
side effects so far recorded if if
however you need the neutrals so the
neutrals are the things like THC CBD
that's what we call the cannabinoids
after they've been activated by
decarboxylation in other words we take
the acid cannabinoids the plant produces
and generally speaking we would heat
them to and and in the process of
heating carbon dioxide is released and
the acid forms are turned into the
neutral forms neutral form of THC a is
hc' Delta 9 THC and that is psychoactive
and it's believed that the psycho
activity is a result of the binding
between the Delta 9 THC and a cb1
receptor in the cells that are
concentrated in the nervous system of
mammals and humans right in particular
um the THC a does not bind to that same
receptor nor does CBD bind significantly
to that receptor and so CAC because of
its specific qualities does convey that
psycho activity and almost none of the
other cannabinoids do right so in order
to get from what the plant produces the
acid cannabinoids to the neutral
cannabinoids it has to be heat you don't
heat it then you you still have those
acid Kannamma there's another process
that the aging process which is really a
longer-term slow oxidation process that
produces some others that's kind of at
the bottom of this slide most important
of those is probably CB n CB n is a
cannabinoid the oxidation a partial
oxidation of THC and that CBN molecule
has been found to be very sedative so it
is if you're looking to to cure insomnia
then get relief from insomnia choosing a
sample that has a significant amount of
CBN in it is probably not a bad idea of
a place to start once again looking at
all of those different cannabinoids we
actually measure
significantly more than this so this is
just a subset of the hundred or so that
cannabis produces and we look at a
couple dozen of them but the important
parts here all of the the cannabinoids
listed here have some kind of medicinal
effect I guess CBL is not on there and a
couple of the others there's some
question marks that work is ongoing with
other places but each one of those
medicinal effects has been reported in
peer-reviewed literature and then to the
right there's the list
the terpenoids again you can't probably
read all those but there's a lot of
terpenoids there's a lot of cannabinoids
and so understanding all of those
different things is is kind of what
we're trying to do and when as we
understand pieces of the puzzle we try
to communicate that so looking back at
the terpenoids and getting back to the
question of what's what's indica and
what sativa how can I tell what's going
to give me a set aid of affect versus an
uplifting effect well it's mostly in the
terpenes some terpenoids like borneol
and living out little ool and Citronelle
all and Niroula doll have a significant
anti insomniac effects or acid ativ
effect some of the the terpenoids like
limonene and alpha pining and baby carry
off lean and not to have that sedate of
effect and can even have an energetic
effect and so it appears to us from our
initial investigations that it's those
differences in the terpenoids that makes
the difference between whether one
experience is an up heady active high or
a down sedate of high and so the
difference between the original indicas
and sativas is very likely a difference
in the terpenoids
interpreted content and that's
definitely something that were we're
pursuing the research on and we're
trying to trace back to mmm
what the original indicas and sativas
might have been producing of course
that's a problem for both the chemists
and the geneticists to work together on
and hopefully we'll have some more
information coming out about that sin
but ultimately what we really feel is
that this is unacceptable that we can't
just be putting cannabis out there and
just saying just calling it cannabis
because there's so many different
potentials that that depend intimately
on the content that we can't just say
this is cannabis right there's got to be
some more information for the end user
to be able to make some rational choices
and so part of that of course is being
able to look at some data from test
results and get an idea of what the
different varietals are and hopefully
give some information
to the end-user so they can make some
rational choices so an easy contrast is
to look at these two strains they call
them strains they're varietals they have
very very different chemical profiles
the one on the left is mostly pink
that's ringo's gift and the the outer
ring is mostly pink which indicates that
it produces mostly CBD a in the plant
it's listed as CBD here because the CBD
is the compound that works seems to work
best for things like anti-seizure and so
on so there's not much THC in that
Ringo's gift strain and so that would be
a very different medicinal effect just
from the out you know just from that one
set of chemicals and on the right again
THC CBD being on the outer ring and chem
dogs chem dog is predominantly THC
almost no CBD that sample when you heat
it will convey significant
psychoactivity right whereas the ring
those gifts will convey almost no psycho
activity inside of the circle we give
even more information so there's a an
imaginary horizontal line through the
center and then above that there are
five bar graphs four or five bars you
know it's showing the content of five
different cannabinoids and below that
line going down our five bars showing
the content of five different terpenoids
and you can see that again between these
two varietals or strains there's a very
significant difference in the content if
we look at what typically comes through
our door ways on any given day the vast
majority is high THC so stuff that's
going to create psycho activity when
heated here are a couple of like six
different strains now they have
different names on them they look very
similar until you start looking at some
of the very specific details looking on
the inside to look at those five
cannabinoids and the five terpenoids
that are presented inside the Rings
there are some subtle differences but in
general most of what comes through looks
kind of like this and they've been
hybridized over decades so that the
content is often very very similar there
are subtle differences and for certain
people those subtle differences may
become very important in terms of what
the medicinal effect is that they get
and compared to what they're seeking all
right so we often get asked why do we
care about testing cannabis we don't
test most other foods all right so one
important reason is well cannabis is
frequently inhaled right so in terms of
when we're talking about say a mold
contamination or something like that for
most people with with with intact immune
systems eating a little bit of mold is
something that we do every day every
time we consume fresh fruits and
vegetables and our bodies are set up to
pretty well protect us by enzymes and
processes in the stomach and intestines
that will help protect us against those
things if we're inhaling though if we're
hailing cannabis directly into the lungs
then all of those processes aren't in
play and so now we have to worry about
is that a problem and certainly it has
been identified as a serious potential
problem for people with reduced immune
response so people who might be on
chemotherapy or who might have an
acquired immune deficiency or many other
reasons and so some of those pathogens
that can exist on the plant even if the
source isn't necessarily the plant it's
something else that's been deposited on
the plant or fallen on the plant those
pathogens are not necessarily killed in
the heating process you're only heating
a very small part and inhaling through a
larger part a lot of the time even that
does not kill the spores and the
pathogens sufficiently and there are a
number of cases reported in the
literature where aspergillosis is one
without potential possibility from a
person with a reduced immune system
inhaling contaminated cannabis so the
fact that it's being inhaled is one
reason that you might want to test
cannabis even though you don't test
spinach cannabis is also a very
high-value product a single plant
outdoor plant might produce several
pounds even upwards of many even ten or
more pounds of can usable cannabis at
the end and so that those plants might
be worth tens of thousands of dollars
each that's very different from the
spinach and broccoli when a cannabis
grower gets a sick plant they're looking
at a potential loss of many thousands of
dollars the temptation to try and use
extreme means to keep that plant alive
and make it to harvest are there in
cannabis where they're not in many and
other products so that's another reason
that cannabis might be a little
different from the rest of the food that
we test and then as I've already
mentioned cannabis is frequently used by
people who do have suppressed immune
system so it's it's not that that's an
uncommon occurrence so it's very well
known that people who are experiencing
many of the side effects of state
chemotherapy get relief by using
cannabis so it's important that
especially those people know what
they're getting so I and this I know
I've made some statements there that
some people will say wait a minute
cannabis has never hurt anybody
well and that's true as far as we know
and the CDC isn't allowed to study this
so we don't know all of the details but
it is true that there are no known
reports of cannabis by itself ever
causing causing death all right so
there's there's no overdose that has
caused death in any human know there are
however numerous cases in the literature
and many other reports of cannabis being
the source of pathogens or in some
potential cases maybe even being
contaminated
pesticides that have caused harm to to
humans and so it's those aspects that we
seek to to either eliminate or at least
detect by testing so that we know if
there's a hazard that people have to
consider before they alright so so we
have a whole bunch of active compounds
that people would like to have some
information about or people would
benefit from having this information
about then there are a bunch of
contaminants right so now we talk about
the fact that we have markets all over
the world that are unable because of the
the the structures of governments and
the degree of being legal in one form
and not illegal in another or illegal at
one level of government legal in other
levels all of that stuff has led to a
situation using where individual
regulators either various states in the
United States or different countries
different countries in the EU
outside of the EU all of these different
places are having to enact regulations
where they're they're working on on
aspects that they don't usually oversee
that's usually done at a more
overarching and a general level at
federal government's and and so on so
excuse me um I want to talk a little bit
about what it is that is being regulated
and where um so first of all most places
are requiring testing for at least the
major cannabinoids and almost always at
least a few of the minor cannabis again
the major cannabinoids are being the THC
and CBD right so how much of each of
those compounds is present in some cases
there's also some requirements to test
for terpenes but most places don't but
many states in the u.s. do now and in
several countries are enacting that kind
of legislation and then of course the
land mines are the safety testing almost
every market that's gone live in the
last several years now has included some
kind of safety testing in the in
addition to at least some rudimentary
testing of the active content people has
been at there long before any of these
regulators were interested or even
thought about doing it so we started
testing in California in 2008 we very
rapidly identified the first high CBD
strain we identified the first high THC
V strain at Halen we created the first
microbiological safety screen for yeast
and mold we developed an instant potency
test for using near-infrared radiation
to get very rapid response on the major
cannabinoids THC and CBD first
successful genetic cannabis sex
identification test so for those of you
who don't know the female plants that
have not been pollinated are by far the
best producers and so nobody wants any
males anywhere near their females that
might produce pollen and reduce in fact
sometimes reducing yields by 20 to 25
percent and therefore males have to be
called very early so we've got a sex
test that identifies males and not males
from the very earliest stages of a seed
opening up we've also got other genetic
tests genetic tests for whether a string
will become a high CBD producer or high
THC producer or mixture and of course
you've already seen the strain
fingerprints that are trademarked method
of trying to convey as much of that
information as possible in terms of the
landmines we're looking at pesticides
microbes metals mycotoxins and in the
of concentrated extracts of the
essential oils we will often be required
to look for residual solvents left over
from the from that extraction process
for the other compounds for the the
cannabinoids and terpenoids we also need
to know how much is there so people know
how much to use so using a few
milligrams is right for some people
using many tens of milligrams is right
for others if that gets mixed up the
people who are using just a few
milligrams when they should be using
many tens don't get the effect they need
and people using many tens when they're
used to using just a few milligrams are
usually not very happy either so on both
sides we've got to be real careful about
what is being being produced and make
sure that the end user has the
information they need to choose the
right medicine for them just given an
overview of kind of the different
markets where we are interacting with
regulators we have about nine different
states with labs open or opening very
soon and several others are in
negotiations we have now including the
US I guess we have six different
countries so we've got Canada Mexico
Jamaica Israel Spain and then there's
several other European nations and and
we're branching out into Asia and South
America as well as we as we speak and so
this there's this global expansion our
our goal is to bring useful meaningful
and yet cost-effective testing to
anybody anywhere that wants to buy
cannabis and use it okay so that's our
goal and so we have a very large
devotion to the the testing industry we
also do a lot of research and
development I'm going to tell you a
little bit about it now
out of that research and development is
in detecting pathogens and other
contaminants in a very cost-effective
manner some of the methods that we need
to use that have been established and
used for a long time are not
particularly cost-effective and we're
very cognizant in the fact that the end
user is the source of all the money in
this chain so it's those patients those
those consumers who are buying the
product at the end that are paying for
everything in this system so everything
has to be as efficient and meaningful as
possible it has to be meaningful to be
worth what it costs right and in
addition steep hill does also do some
venture capital work where if we find
companies with really good ideas
operating in a space that that we can
contribute we will definitely discuss
the idea of helping them along using our
R&D labs and the massive amounts of data
that we already have and can collect
quickly to help those other programs
long so talking just a little bit more
about what that means when we have such
a wide network we have and we have all
of these different jurisdictions with
different regulations that may be that
our labs are held to be accountable to
just to give you an example if we just
look at the list of microbiological and
mycotoxin analytes that might be
required so most of these are
microbiological pathogens right or
relations related things so here are in
fact California isn't even on here this
slide was made before the California
regs came out in November so what do we
got we got six different states and you
can see down the the left hand side
there's a whole bunch of different
microbiological targets mm-hmm and if
you look about one two three four but
five from the bottom is salmonella and
you can see that of these six these six
states two of those states require us to
test for salmonella and four do not I
can tell you that we
for Salmonella in a number of different
markets and we find it all the time
hey it's not it's not the most you know
we see other things more frequently for
sure but Salmonella shows up frequently
enough that we think it's something that
should be tested for we've developed a
very inexpensive way to test for so it
doesn't cost a whole lot to add that
target recently we had a client submit
11 different batch samples so 11 batches
of of cannabis flowers 5 of those 11
tested positive for Salmonella 5 of 11
which is obviously clearly there's some
source of contamination right and so
they were able to trace it back very
likely to they had an employee who had
food poisoning very bad food poisoning
and worked through it and hailed
cannabis in a way that was not safe uh
and so that was identified we were able
to figure out what it was but I'm
telling you places that dark testing for
Salmonella are not doing their their
patients and consumers any favor in fact
we we participated with some MDS at the
University of California Davis Medical
Center to look at what different types
of pathogens might exist in cannabis or
might be carried by cannabis and so we
at random chose 20 different samples 20
different flower samples we collected
DNA because we can transfer DNA from
cannabis to or DNA from whatever is on
the cannabis so we we didn't
differentiate so we got cannabis DNA and
the DNA from whatever else was living on
the cannabis or present on the cannabis
at that time we can send that DNA to the
University of California we can't send
them any cannabis so they couldn't do
this work on their own but we could
collect the DNA and then just send them
the DNA they analyzed the DNA and this
shows you a whole bunch there's there's
a couple of dozen different mostly
pathogenic microorganisms that they had
tested for by DNA and
you can see that out of those 20 samples
all 20 of them had something so the blue
hits are all different types of things
the list on the left there's there's a
bunch of bacteria there's a bunch of
molds at any rate you can see that the
need to test cannabis and the is there
especially in this case so in this case
these doctors were particularly
interested because they had a relatively
young chemotherapy patient who was being
treated for a very treatable form of
cancer with a not so horrible
chemotherapy treatment but that person
and another we're using cannabis and
developed a lung infection and at least
one of those patients died from the lung
infection and the belief is by these MDS
that that lung infection likely came
from contaminated cannabis there was no
cannabis left to test so the direct link
can't be shown but it does that this
graph does show that 20 samples at
random every one of those 20 has
something okay so how do do that oh do
we assess the safety in general cannabis
is not too different from a lot of other
commodities it's different than wheat
and corn and it's different than spinach
and broccoli but it has some of the same
characteristics so what we generally are
doing is making modifications to methods
that are already established and in
place in some cases in other cases we're
coming up with with ways to do rapid
inexpensive testing of a large supply
chain right on a batch by batch basis so
we do have a new method for testing for
molds mildew yeast bacteria and looking
for specific species in addition to
wider generic kind of tests and we do
that both by using qpcr in other words
DNA based tests and we also do it by
culture where we grow up cultures of
various samplings from our batches
testing for for pesticides mycotoxins
and things like plant clock plant growth
regulators are generally done using
tandem mass spectrometry and a
chromatography method so we do both
liquid chromatography and gas
chromatography followed up by 10 mass
spectrometry usually triple quadrupole
mass spectrometry we look for heavy
metals contamination that's done by
inductively coupled plasma mass
spectrometry that method in particular
is very very similar to methods employed
for other commodities residual solvents
is something kind of unique to cannabis
where we're looking for solvents less
left over after making these these
concentrated extracts of essential oils
and then for active compounds we use
liquid chromatography and gas
chromatography because of the acid
cannabinoids degrade upon heating uh
gas chromatography is not the best
method to look at cannabinoid content
instead liquid chromatography is used
for that now getting all of these
different things to work in this
particularly complex matrix so cannabis
then has has had over 500 different
components in that matrix of cannabis
identified so it's a very very complex
matrix to be used for any kind of these
these tests where we're looking for very
very small amounts of contaminants and
I'm worrying about whether there's some
interference between what's actually in
the cannabis versus the stuff we're
looking for so that turns out to be
difficult we've done a really good job
we've got a DNA test that we can do
dozens of organisms all at once and one
swell foop so to speak and and so that
is helping make an inexpensive and yet
very powerful microbiology test of
particular importance again
because cannabis is is such a high value
component or product
the temptation to use toxins pesticides
in particular to control the the attack
of various pests is important
the major pests are insects and and
molds and so most of the pesticides that
we see are indeed for the treatment of
molds and and insects spider mites are
the biggest but there's a few others
here's four of the most commonly
observed in California so Michael a
mutant L is particularly important
because Michael butanol is pretty safe
there's a lot of it used in grapes it's
pretty safe if you if you ingest small
amounts of it very small amounts of it
ingested into your your stomach and
intestines have bench that deemed by the
EPA to not be particularly toxic to
humans and other other mammals however
when it's heated like it might be in a
cannabis flower it releases cyanide and
that causes some concern for
toxicologists that significant amounts
of cyanide certainly are not very
healthy
so Michael butanol is is a fungicide
that's used for these two to defend
against mold and it's by far the most
frequently observed pesticide in the
samples that we have analyzed to date so
that shows up in a lot of samples I'll
talk a little bit more about the
different sources
there's a couple other up here that are
insecticides imidacloprid a bur macton
attribute ecla Butte Rizal is actually a
plant growth regulator but also works as
a fungicide so these are just a handful
depending on the jurisdiction we might
be looking at for a dozen or two dozen
or in California now it's 66 different
pesticides so that because as it is
again something that varies
jurisdiction to jurisdiction and
obviously we're doing our best to try
and communicate what's important and
what isn't in California for example we
look for some reason where we have items
on that list of 66 pesticides that
haven't been manufactured or distributed
or been allowed to be used for decades
in California so there is no source of
it possible you didn't even so it's not
clear to me why some of those compounds
would still be on that list and be
costing money down the line to the
people who are paying for it but for
sure the pesticides that are used
they're often used in very significant
amounts so you have a $10,000 plant and
it's gotten sick its infested with mold
or it's infested with insects there's a
strong strong temptation to use
significant amounts of pesticides to try
and get that market get that plant to
make it all the way to market so that
you recoup some of the expenses that
you've put in so remember in most places
in the world still you can't get crop
insurance so you can't get insurance on
these types of crops even though they're
worth so much money
so that's a some aspect of the
cultivation that is different for
cannabis compared to other things so in
terms of the sources of pesticides
clearly intentional application is one
possible source of pesticides we have
worked with a number of folks in trying
to to mitigate their exposure to
pesticides in their in their gardens and
we know that there are a number of ways
that pesticides can get in there
unintentionally right so one is somebody
actually uses a product knowingly but
without knowing that pesticides are part
of that product so that has happened
many many times in particular you know a
product that has Michael butanol it's
written on the label but people never
read that far on the label they didn't
understand it they did use it and it
showed up and we found it and that's you
know the ultimate solution obviously was
not use that product anymore once they
were educated in some cases you might be
buying soil or other amendments that are
coming in from a third party where
pesticides are already present in that
amendment there can be pesticides
present in cuttings that are used for
propagation I'm going to talk about that
a little bit more in just a minute
there's also drift so if if your
neighbor is growing corn and they have a
helicopter or plane come through and
spray pesticide and you're right next
door or just down the way you're very
likely gonna get some some pesticide
drifting over on the wind or in the
water
or in the blown soil so there's a number
of different ways that these pesticides
can come up and obviously we want to
help our clients figure out how to
mitigate those processes so that we can
help them produce and this one in
particular was was a something that we
decided we would look into because we
had a number of clients who were very
dedicated to growing clean cannabis
swore up and down they never use
pesticides and yet we tested and all of
their batches had small amounts of
pesticides on them usually Michael
butanol something used more up and down
they didn't use any lytx and we believed
some of them at least that they were
were being truthful about the the lack
of use and so we looked into the ways
that cannabis is propagated and one of
the main ways cannabis is propagated is
by what we call clones they're not
really clones they're cuttings so in
other words there's a mother plant and
you take cuttings off of that mother
plant and then you induce those cuttings
to create roots and then you can
transplant them as roots and grow them
up into plants well it turns out that
this process of taking cuttings and
growing them up very often weakens the
immune system of the plants so they
become more susceptible to things like
mold and perhaps insects in some cases
they don't never grow a true tap root
and so their root
systems are a little weaker and so on
and it turns out that a lot of clone
makers just hey they're there cuttings
and immediately treat them with Michael
you know to prevent the the formation of
mold while these plants are in that
cutting stage and susceptible well it
turns out that Michael butanol is what
we call a systemic pesticide so it
doesn't just exist on the outside of the
leaves and stem and stuff it actually
makes its way in the plant and in this
process not only was the plant
contaminated with my club you know but
they the root system and the root ball
and the material that is rooted in we're
all contaminated with my club you know
so that when these clones get
transplanted into the field or wherever
they still have Michael a butanol in
them at harvest measurable amounts of
that pesticide at harvest when we tested
on we went and collected in this case
120 something different clones mostly
from the state of California but not
exclusively and when we tested those 124
clones over 80% were contaminated with
pesticides and almost all with my club
you know so that this in itself was a
way that pesticides were getting into
the chain without people really
understanding why or how I'm glad to say
that we've been able to raise that
awareness and people now know about it
and the clone makers mostly are changing
the ways that they make clones so we'd
like to promote global standards we've
learned a lot from the different
regulatory markets that we're in and
we'd like to convey that we'd like to be
able to to help markets advance into
this regulatory scheme but with the
right balance of safety and efficacy and
yet keeping the costs down alright so we
everywhere we go the priority is do no
harm right make sure it's safe right
make sure that what's going on the
shelves is stuff that people have the
information they need to decide whether
they want to buy it
so so
making sure it's it's not contaminated
with bad stuff and making sure that what
is in there in terms of good stuff is
listed and identified um obviously
regulatory systems like this that's at
hat it's a government thing it's
government government regulatory
oversight we believe that's essential in
this in this case and for the various
reasons that Prettyman said and one of
the things that we encourage anybody who
is a regulator or a legislator getting
into trying to figure your artists there
he real penalties for the people who
cheat because there are very strong
financial incentives to cheat and that's
not only on the producer and and
dispensary levels but also on the lab
levels so generally speaking the higher
the amounts of THC or some cases CBD in
the medicine the more valuable that
medicine is and so if if those numbers
get inflated either because the producer
is cherry-picking their best samples to
send to get testing we always advise
that the labs do the sampling and not
the the producers or dispensaries so or
or distributors for that matter so this
is an independent party either the
government regulators or the labs should
be doing the the sampling and then you
know so so that you can't just
cherry-pick and then in addition to to
the increase in the value associated
with higher values higher assay values
for the THC and CBD obviously if a lab
falsifies safety testing and passes
samples and batches that are really
contaminated and shouldn't be passed now
we have potentially harmful material
making it to the shelves in the
distributors where it can get
distributed to patients and people who
are potentially very ill-equipped to
handle the the presence of those
contaminants so in
addition to setting up a system of
regulations that allows for that the the
testing and monitoring of those
important beneficial and and contaminant
species we also then have to have that
regulatory system have enough
transparency so that the cheers will be
discouraged and caught and then the
regulations and and legislation has to
have in it significant penalties to the
people who are caught cheating and who
are basically risking the health of
their neighbors for a few extra dollars
alright so I'm just gonna kind of fire
through a few important things that we
think are important for for any
regulatory system the labs themselves
should be required to prove their
competence and a big part of that are is
using what are called proficiency tests
in many jurisdictions and we encourage
this as well
firing that laboratories be accredited
by say ISO one seven oh two five
accreditation agencies and that in
addition to kind of there are some
requirements in there for proficiency
testing but we actually recommend a
higher level of proficiency testing we
also recommend that the labs build into
their system maybe a method of
transparency where any regulator can
look in and see what's happening or has
happened pretty much any sample and so
we have and we advocate for systems
where that is is clear and that is a big
big deterrent the labs trying to cheat
if they know that it's easy and that at
anytime a regular could regulate err
could be looking into the process and
looking for the the key points where
cheating can occur
and those are pretty well outlined then
that it goes a long long way having an
internal electronic sample tracking
system where once it comes in the door
and goes out again absolutely imperative
that regulators have all of that
visibility right and part of that is
part of the general good precedent but
the cannabis industry requires kind of a
very detailed approach all right I think
we've already kind of covered a number
of reasons why testing is needed but
basically if we're thinking about
cannabis as medicine like very many
places in the world do then medicine
needs some quality control and quality
assurance and again it should do no harm
it shouldn't be contaminants in there
that are harmful or not in terms of how
we contribute to global standards for
cannabis testing it's not just about the
testing regular test regulatory testing
is one arm of that but we also engage in
we have a PhD cultivation scientist who
works with integrated pest pest
management understands why people are
using certain pesticides what happens
with those pesticides how can they get
away from using those pesticides we do
that stuff we have processed analytics
which allows producers to run tests
thing that they're processing whether
that be growing during the breeding and
flower reading and planting stages all
through to the flowering stages and then
third-party validation and collaboration
in that case we work with a number of
different folks regulators and not to to
validate results and to make sure that
the products being produced are what are
desired and are the right ones for the
cohort for whom they're intended so
the research and development projects
I'm gonna move through really kind of
quickly as well one of the things that
we work on quite a bit is understanding
the cannabis genome so we do our own
sequencing and we work with others who
do sequencing to look at various aspects
and identify genes and what they do and
then part of that is using
bioinformatics and in some cases this is
looking at lineages seeing which strains
which which cultivars are related to one
another and how and some of the
important expression of different
medicinal compounds comes about and
could be bred for for example and we
have we've developed some rapid analyses
that allow us to analyze for particular
genetic features and so we can look at
lots and lots of samples to look and see
if they have particular features after
we've produced the right probes for
example I'm gonna highlight just a few
things in some cases for example you
probably know about human DNA in human
DNA if I get a sample of human DNA and I
want to compare that to to lots of other
human DNA samples we can by looking in
the right place they always tell which
individual that DNA came from and I can
be down to a one part per billion right
or parts for many billions type of
accuracy so we're looking into cannabis
to see is there are there other things
that we can look for in terms of the DNA
in chemist so we are certainly looking
for particular traits whether a strain
has the the capability of producing
particular cannabinoids THC versus CBD
is a big one for example some strains
don't have the capability of producing
CBD and so no matter what you do to them
you're not gonna get CBD from that plant
unless you've got the right genes then
you can get this evening right so
we do a lot of the chemical analysis and
merge that with the data from the
genetic analysis and are able to to
identify aspects of the genetic material
that leads to those traits and in
hopefully what leads to the expression
of those traits not just the potential
but the actual expression we look we can
see changes in in the DNA that lead to
dick changes in the Mito amino acid
structures of the proteins that are in
the family and we can always zoom in on
specific genes and look to see how
they're changing from one string to
another and there's a number of things
that leads to but probably the marker
development so that breeders can choose
what they want to have in their cannabis
plant at the end and be reasonably
certain that that's what they're going
to get after having a whole season or
investing a lot of money to grow these
plants up this is give you an idea
somebody that we know was looking for
high CBD trait they wanted to have a lot
of high CBD plants and here's a couple
of dozen crosses hybridizations and they
brought in and you can see that only
about a third of them actually we're
high in CBD so the dots towards the top
so basically the CBD THC a ratio is what
we're plotting on the on the on the y
axis there along the x axis are all the
different tries to do that and you can
see that there's only about seven of
those couple dozen strains that achieve
that high level of CP relative to the
produce THC and not budget of any CBD um
looking at the THC a synthase specific
so these it's a little bit hard to see
obviously and the details aren't that
important to you unless you're trying to
work specifically in this field but we
can sequence the THC a synthase gene so
that's a known gene now and we can tell
that there
certain changes that are commonly
encountered when we look at different
individuals and so the presence or
absence of those changes helps us to
understand lineages and evolution of the
plant so here's the THC a synthase gene
here's the CBD a synthase gene so again
you can see in certain areas where
they're perfect for lots of individuals
but not all the individuals we can use
those kinds of changes as I said to gain
an insight into lineage what came first
and where did it come from and so here's
just a little bit of a snapshot of from
analyzing the CBD a synthase gene and
looking at a dozen or so different
cultivars that we've tested to see what
exactly is the the relationship of those
things one last example of why testing
is needed this is a slide from one of
our club early Mary who's at the
Technion in the University in Israel and
this actually shows just cannabinoids on
four different growth sites where they
thought they had the exact same genetics
what they also noticed particular study
what they were they were using this
cannabis in a clinical study and when
the strain when that when the source of
the cannabis changed there was enough of
a change in the chemical content that
the results of the study were affected
and they noticed it immediately and so
one other reason that we need this kind
of regulated reproducible testing from
one spot to another is that if we're
going to do these kinds of clinical
studies to understand more about the
genetics and the medicinal effects then
we have to be able to measure those
things accurately and reproduce so I'm
going to go ahead and and and skip a few
other traits that we looked at
terms of terpenes and I'm going to go
right to the meat of our conclusions so
the the most important conclusion that I
can come up with is that we would like
to produce systematic nomenclature so
that in the future M DS pharmacists
healers in general will know what to
prescribe to which patient right now the
situation is dire we have names that are
made up on the fly in some cases made up
and changed multiple times and in a lot
of cases names that you wouldn't want to
have your child here right and so we got
to get away from that we have to be able
to to inform MDS they understand what
goes to
so in conclusion cannabis is this
complex matrix we have a few things that
we can do to it that are just like any
other matrix just like any other
commodity but in a lot of cases we have
to tweak it a little bit to make it work
for cannabis certainly the other most
important thing is what you see is not
always what you get you can't tell by
looking at it you have test results
before you really understand what's in
it and the industry as a whole and
regulators are all evolving towards
requiring testing and hopefully we can
all get on the same page with what's
required for testing so with that I'm
gonna just put up a slide here of all
the various spots that we've been in the
news recently certainly look for steep
hill we've got a lot of educational
content out there and once again you
thank you thank you lab roots for
letting us join you in helping to
educate some folks thank you dr. land
for that informative presentation we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your
and click the send button we'll answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for so let's get started first
question is I thought that cannabis was
only about THC or CBD I am surprised to
learn your test for 17 cannabinoids what
do you see on the horizon that is
exciting to you well certainly one of
the things on the horizon I see that's
exciting is the ability of folks who
actually do human clinical trials so
that we can understand what some of
these different compounds are really
useful for unfortunately not that's not
happening in the United States because
of the federal regulations or illegality
but it's happening in lots of other
places and so we're really excited to be
involved in in Israel and Jamaica and
Canada Mexico to be able to do some
things to understand and and the reason
we look for all these different
cannabinoids is almost all of them I've
already been shown to have important
medicinal properties and if we can make
our plants produce the things that we
want or make something else produce the
things that we want then then that
should be less expensive for the end
user do you expect you'll be testing for
more cannabinoids and turkeys as
research expands yes and no so I think
we've we're expanding the number of
cannabinoids and terpenoids that we test
for for sure in a lot of cases we've
already kind of reached the information
overload I mean some what we really want
to do for doctors and patients really is
to simplify that process so instead of
having to read down a whole long list of
compounds which they still can when when
they're educated to understand that we'd
like to give kind of a simplified guide
and so in some cases in some
jurisdictions it may not make sense to
test for everything because that's
expensive so we want to make sure that
it's cost-effective I didn't realize
that ecoli Salmonella and molds on
cannabis for a potential health concern
how frequently do you see these
contaminants in the lab yeah well so a
coli and Salmonella we see relatively
infrequently no on the order of a
percent we're less of samples so it's
relatively rare that we see them but not
so rare that we would want to say no it
doesn't make sense test for them because
if you get the wrong kind of E coli or
Salmonella in particularly in a
sensitive patient that can be a real big
problem all right an it can lead to
death so we want to make sure that that
information is out there and frankly
we've worked on a test to make it so
cheap test for those things that there
is no good reason it's not right how
often do we see them yeah I guess
answered that less than a percent or so
how can I be assured that product i buy
is tested correctly yeah that's a
difficult one
um if you're in a regulated market where
testing is required then your best bet
is to keep track of what those what your
state regulators have said in terms of
which labs are accredited which ones can
test so usually that will be controlled
for by the regulators in a regulated
market if you're not in a regulated
market it's a caveat emptor situation if
the labs are not regulated we see in
every market that we've been in we see
cheaters you see labs that falsify their
records and falsify the results so that
they increase our inflate the THC values
beyond what they really are and where
they pass samples pass batches into the
market that should be failed for
contamination either by pesticides or by
microbiology so
push for regulations in your
jurisdiction and and and that's really
your your best hope for for fixing it
for everybody what effects have you
heard of in the patient community what
symptoms as well well it's always hard
to relate the symptoms observed to
anything specific because in in most
markets that that work is just starting
so for example in Colorado and in the
state of Washington
they don't actually require us to be
tested for pesticides instead what they
work on is when somebody brings them a
complaint then they go investigate and
we've had big product recalls in in both
of those places where stuff after the
fact was tested and found to be heavily
contaminated same thing happened in
Canada for janna had a huge recall
several different of their major
producers because they found significant
amounts of several pesticides and of
course everybody says oh we didn't know
so in the end almost all of those places
are going to do the to the we want to
test every matched you know trust but
verify there's an important reason that
that phrase is kind of come into
existence so yeah we trusted gonna do it
right but just in case we're gonna
verify it by testing the pesticide gave
you shared is kind of scary is the
cannabis industry aware of the problem
and what are they doing to fix it yeah
that when we we got some of that
pesticide data we were we were very
concerned interned with was that now we
had messed it up because it was so much
pesticide in so many samples but we
checked and rechecked and and did the
samples multiple times and give multiple
studies and every time we came up with
the same results and that is there's a
lot of pesticide use and specifically in
the California
market where we've done the majority of
that tested acting but I'll tell you
what most of that most of those studies
were over a year ago
and we're into the new new season and
we're seeing a lot less of it now I have
to say in California right now less than
1% of the cannabis in California is
going through any kind of a test and so
we can't make any brand you know so
maybe we're seeing less because the
people who are using pesticides are
choosing not to get it tested by us
that's certainly a possibility but the
stuff that we are testing in general is
cleaner than Houston so what I think
we're making progress on it
well we have time for one more question
if a product says it is organic can this
statement be trusted in the United
States the designation and certification
as being organic is something that's
conveyed by the federal government and
since cannabis is illegal on a federal
level there can be no certified organic
in abysus
that's fortunately on the status well
thank you I would like to once again
thank dr. lam for his presentation and I
would like to thank laberd's for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
on demand for on man viewing through
June 29 2018 you'll receive an email
from laberd's letting you know when this
webcast will be available for a replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that is all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye